moi j'ai opéré m en juillet les narnia
jo 2016
un petit cancer du sein droit avec un
traitement conservateur consultations de
suivi pour cette patiente le cancer du
sein est le plus répandu des cancers
féminins
il touche une femme sur huit en france
il faut que la patiente soit suivi c'est
ce qu'on leur conseille régulièrement
annuellement par leur gynécologue
traitant qui pratique un examen clinique
dessin examen mammaire puis un examen
gynécologique et qui peut soit dépistée
quelque chose soit en tout cas être
attentif aux facteurs nourrissent de la
patiente et l'adresser faire ça
mammographie et son échographie à titre
individuel ces deux praticiens reçoivent
conjointement des patients adressés par
des confrères après un premier examen
la palpation annuelle est la première
étape d'un dépistage
la mammographie elle permet de révéler
les tumeurs dépistage permet de
démystifier des lésions très petit qu'on
appelle des lésions infraclinique c'est
à dire qu'elle ne pourrait pas être
perçu ni par la patiente elle même y par
un médecin lors d'un examen
c'est le
des visages mammographie qui permet de
détecter ces très petites lésions et qui
permet donc des prises en charge un
stade très précoce
chaque année 54 mille nouveaux cas sont
détectés en france une fois par semaine
à versailles oncologue médecin nucléaire
ou encore radiologue concernés se
rassemble on a discuté aujourd'hui de
medan
d'une jeune patiente de 37 ans qui s'est
auto palper un nodule donc fait une
mammographie comme les nodules et est
suspect et le radiologue lui a fait une
biopsie et j'ai revu avec le résultats
de la biopsie qui a retrouvé un cancer
du sein l'objectif de ces réunions sont
discutées de la prise en charge des
patients avec l'oeil des différents
spécialistes qui voit à chaque fois la
maladie sous un angle différent sur les
possibilités thérapeutiques dans le
domaine qui concerne justement le
médecin qui discutent du dossier
l'intérêt étant d'assurer la meilleure
prise en charge du patient
les médecins du centre hospitalier de
versailles opère une centaine de
patientes chaque année un cancer détecté
un stade précoce peut être guéri dans 9
cas sur 10 en 2016 seule une femme sur
deux se faisait dépister